good evening everybody members and
officers of the council welcome to the
meeting of the standards committee
welcome to the public again
um fire evacuation procedure if the
firearm is activated
please vacate the offices via the stairs
either through the security door
or opposite the lifts in the foyer
please do not use the lifts
please assembling holy square on the
green officers will assist you and
advise when it is deemed safe for you to
return to the chamber
does anyone intend to film the meeting
any member of the public object no i
don't think so
i'd advise that if filming takes place
anyone in attendance in the public area
fine can everybody ensure that their
mobile phones are turned to silent and
they are not used to make or receive
calls in the chamber whilst the meeting
is
in progress please note this meeting is
being live stream for members of the
public
except for any items of business or
exempt or confidence confidential
information is considered
following the exclusion of the press and
the public from the meeting
this meeting is also being recorded and
will be broadcast on the internet
with any member who wishes to speak
under council procedure rule 20.1 please
announce it now
[Music]
good apologies for absence
i've received apologies from lee
welbrook and dennis james are there any
other apologies
minutes of the meeting held on the 9th
of march 2021
i moved that the minutes of the meeting
held on the 9th of march to be approved
and signed as a correct record
could i have a second to please council
fellows thank you unless any of anyone
objects
to the minutes i'll take them as agreed
thank you
are there any decorations of interest
i've got a very brief report um
there isn't a lot to say really we've
had a couple of um
discussions to make in relation to
certain complaints but that's all
covered on the back of the
table as per usual and the same with the
we had a recent crwp meeting
which concerned parental policy and that
is obviously before you this evening
and apart from that everything touchwood
is running extremely smoothly unless
anybody's got any questions we'll move
on
good
parental leave policy this report was
considered by the constitutional review
working party on the 15th of june
2021 the standards committee can make
recommendations on any element to full
council
the standards committee can also make
recommendations to accompany the report
when it is discussed and agreed
by full council on the 15th of july mr
hughes would you like to introduce a
report please
thank you thank you chairman so
this report is based on an emerging
local government policy trend that has
seen some local councils develop and
adopt
parental leave policies for their
members this report proposes a similar
approach for consideration by
thanksgiving council
there's no legal uh legislative
requirement for the council to adopt a
parental lead policy however having such
a policy would make
to be a progressive approach and would
mean that thank district council would
be at the forefront
of councils to adopt such a policy now
whilst obviously this policy would cover
all existing councillors
this policy isn't really aimed at those
people who are currently counsellors but
much more aimed at those who are
considering becoming a councillor
the policy is designed to help break
down one of the significant barriers to
becoming a councillor
and ties in well with the council's
dependence carers allowance making it
easier for those
who have or are considering starting a
family to become counsellors
as outlined at paragraph 1.5 of the
report it identified that
one-third of female counselors of
child-bearing age found the lack of
maternity leave to be a
barrier to fulfilling their role and
this this uh
policy can be a small part of a way of
addressing
that issue so what's the policy actually
going to do
firstly it will introduce a blanket
exemption
that parental leave is an acceptable
reason for
nottingham not attending a council
meeting within a six-month period
as i'm sure you're aware section 85 of
the local government
act 1972 requires that councillors
attend at least one meeting of council
in a six month period otherwise that you
would be disqualified
uh obviously you fall fail with this if
you were taking nine months of
maternity leave so hence that exemption
we don't feel that it's appropriate that
if somebody
wants to take some parental leave then
and that would then take them past the
six-month point
that's not really something that should
be coming to council because that's not
really an appropriate
uh people shouldn't be making a judgment
upon that point
it's it should be very cut and dry and
that's a perfectly reasonable reason for
not being here in addition the other
main part of the policy
means that councillors who take parental
leave will be entitled to retain some of
their remuneration
it's important at this stage to point
out that councillors will always be
entitled to their basic allowance
both before and after the implementation
of the policy as the financial parts of
the policy relate only to special
responsibility allowances
so those are the ones you get for being
a chairman or a cabinet member that sort
of thing
uh how much counselors receive is the
main subject of discussion tonight and
there are three options and these are
outlined at paragraph four
of annex one of the reports on page 17
of the agenda
pack they're as follows so there's
option one of paragraph 4.1
and this mirrors the provision for staff
um
so that would be 10 weeks at 90 of their
special responsibility allowance
followed by 16 weeks at 50 of their
special responsibility allowance
and then followed by unpaid leave for
any additional leave up to the 52 weeks
option two of paragraph 4.2 which is six
months of full pay of their responsible
responsibility allowance
with any remaining leave up to the
agreed 52 weeks being unpaid
and then option three which is in line
with the model policy for local
government which is provided by the
local government association
which is receipt of full pay for special
responsibility allowances
uh throughout of the whole leave period
whether that's six months or 52 weeks
this issue uh this specific issue was
discussed at length at the
constitutional review working party
and they recommended to this committee
option two that being the sixth month
uh pay therefore i'd ask members to
consider that recommendation see whether
they concur with it
and if they do make a further
recommendation onto full council or if
they don't then obviously to make an
alternative recommendation to full
council
instead it's also worth pointing out
there are a few other things that came
up
at the crwp meeting which are worth
mentioning so
this policy also covers adoption leave
as well as
[Music]
parental newborn maternity potentially
leave that sort of thing
and if agreed we would be amongst the
first in kent the first councils in kent
to adopt such
policy and as stated in the report just
seven percent of local councils
currently have a formal
parental leave policy in place for their
elected representatives
so if any members have any questions
then i'll have to answer them
counselor bayford
okay um yes i believe they would not as
a
not as a basic counsellor but as the
role because
what the policy would allow the
administration to do is to appoint
another
councillor to act in their stead so
all the time that that person is
enrolled then no i wouldn't say that the
other person
would be actively a
actively taking on that role so for
example um if you had two cap
a cabinet member for for whatever topic
you want
um the other and then they were replaced
by the second
person to be that cabinet member i would
expect the second person to communicate
regularly with that first person to keep
them up to date and keep them informed
but the the the person who's on the
leave shouldn't be then turning up a
meeting saying
or releasing a statement that says we
think that xyz is a fantastic idea or
something like that
that should be the preserve of the the
person who's there as their replacement
counselor
[Music]
can i just ask a question before i come
into cancer cup
if the counselor is absent through
parental leave are they have they still
got voting rights
if anything needs to be voted on in
chamber
as a standard counsellor then um
yeah they would do i would imagine
there's nothing we could do because this
is a
a voluntary scheme there's nothing we
could do to preclude
somebody from turning up obviously if
they were
removed from their committee by the
ruling group
for the period of their um
period of parental leave then evidently
they wouldn't be on the committee so the
only thing that they would be able to
vote on would be something at full
council
but yeah that would be the only um
exception to that council cup
thank you chair um it's not a question
it's more a comment on the policy
actually and i think that
um a policy like this is is very good um
as a council i think we should be
encouraging policies like this because
um it's only right that we have people
from a device
diverse background and we ensure that
we're encouraging those from
all ages and whoever they may be to come
forward and become counsellors and
something like going off and wanting to
have a family or having child care
should not be something that is put in a
way of
um making people want to become
counselors
and that support should be there and i
personally think the option to from this
report
should be supported um by this committee
thank you chair
counselor crittenden thank you i just
wanted to
ask if there were um any explanations to
why
option two was chosen over the others
i think it's i think it's fair to say
that um
there was a proposal for option one
uh to mirror the um to mirror the um
staff scheme it's not a direct mirror
but it's comparable with the staff
scheme
um however i think the root of the
discussion was that
members are members and officers of
officers and so you wouldn't be able to
directly compare
it's like comparing apple's repairs in
the sense of
it's not a direct correspond a direct
relationship
so that option b retained the
um a quite a beneficial
scenario for members but wasn't as
generous as
the full payment option um but was more
generous than
the basic option and members didn't feel
as if
there was a need to be the same as
officers
based on the fact that obviously members
and officers are completely separate
i think that's amazing is that a fair
summary
i think i can just add as well initially
when we looked at this
um the words basic allowance was still
in there
they've obviously been removed because
of the discussions we were having
because obviously councils are entitled
to their allowance and it's just
the special responsibility allowance and
not based on the basic allowance
sits there and stays there and that was
something else that we discussed
for quite some time hence we went
eventually went down the road to option
two and as mr use rightly says
there were initially recommendations for
option one
then following on from quite a lengthy
discussion uh
option two was the one recommended by
the crwp
to come to standards this evening has
anybody else got any questions
council bayford yes just to say i agree
that the option two is quite generous
but i think the benefits
far outweigh the cost to the council
council duckworth um
yeah it's just just a clarification on
the basic allowance so at the moment
um if somebody um were to start but
um once again maternity leave then on
the basic allowance they would just get
that or
forget it first all right yeah that's
something
that's a bit okay thank you
yeah thank you uh so we're discounting
option one
so we're looking at option two and three
so they're pretty much the same apart
from option three
gives the uh additional six months so we
basically we need to decide whether
we're doing to do six months
or twelve months yeah so
is that part of a discussion we should
be having if it's going to are we
allowed to do
because i think we should go for option
3 in 12 months personally my opinion
i mean if if members want to choose
option 1 that's perfectly ok
that's we're not just because crwp said
they didn't want to do it
there's no reason why you may feel that
actually it's a really great idea
so any of those three options are
perfectly okay to
have a debate about obviously some
members have expressed other opinions
that's fine
um yeah it's it's open to
whatever option that members would like
to put forward to council
yeah i mean i i'd i'd i'd discount like
say the difference between officers and
elected members but yeah i mean i i
think it's it's gonna
it's gonna be for some minimum amount of
staff cabinet members are committing
chairman's i think you know we can be a
bit generous here give the full years
in my opinion
i think safe to say at this stage then
that we are discounting option one would
we all agree with that
fine so do we recommend option two or
option three
can we have a show of hands for option
two please
option three
our members agreed
can we just have a formal proposal and a
formal secondary please
council cup and councillor bayford
thank you very much the only other
business is the statistics table
which is attached to the papers has
anybody got
to make any comments at all about the
statistics as you can see
as i said at the start touchwood it's
been relatively quiet
on the complaints front whether kobe's
had something to do with that
we don't know or is it just that you've
all been on your best behavior
anybody got any comments to make
fine i think that is it ladies and
gentlemen members
um we thought it might be short but not
this short it's now
7 16 and i'll bring the meeting to a
close
thank you